all right people we are live wherever
you watch your internet programs and
holy
today is a day it is a day that will
live in infamy or fumi uh depending on
what position you're in uh obviously the
roe v wade decision was just announced
so we are adding that to the docket of
today's friday panel extravaganza and
joining me are president of the
brownstone institute jeffrey a tucker
senior fellow at the clermont institute
dave verboy and editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial libby emmons jeffrey
dave libby welcome to the reuben report
pleasure thank you
uh all right first off before we get
into anything here i have to tell you
because of this roe v wade thing i walk
into the studio today and sitting on my
desk one of my guys printed this out for
me and just left it on my desk there is
clarence thomas
today is obviously a very good day for
him and people that like him yesterday
was his birthday so it almost happened
on his birthday but we got to start with
uh roe v wade being reversed uh got a
little something from town hall to kick
us off here breaking the supreme court
has overturned roe v wade returning
abortion law to the states and libby
since you're joining us today we often
source the post-millennial uh but we did
it for you today uh the supreme court on
wednesday released a ruling in the case
of dub friday jackson
oh
uh right friday why does that say
wednesday
that's game that's
we just copied and pasted it uh yeah we
just copy and paste it the supreme court
on friday released a ruling in the case
of dobbs vs jackson women's health
organization they have overturned roe v
wade which legalized abortion at the
federal level at issue in the case was
whether all restrictions to abortion
prior to viability are constitutional or
not the decision a draft of which was
which was leaked in late april
essentially overturns the landmark 1973
ruling in roe v wade that federally
legalized abortion now the decision on
whether or not abortion is legal returns
to the states so broadly speaking i
think we're all somewhat like-minded on
this and that we're states rights people
we don't like government overreach and
we do like personal choice uh jeffrey i
want to start with you here uh since i
know that so much what i just said there
is in your pedigree it's in your blood
uh i sense you look at this as a good
day
i'm glad it came out this summer rather
than waiting closer to the election my
own prediction is that this whole thing
is going to be not a big existential
threat to privacy and human rights and
everything else all it does is devolve
it to the states
and the states that have liberal laws
now will continue to have liberal laws
those that have tighter laws will
continue to have tighter laws it takes
the battle back to the states and i
think everybody's going to calm down
pretty soon i would give it to in in two
months we'll realize that's not the end
of the world the decision is right and
we can put this as a national issue
behind us and i will be very relieved
for that
wait jeffrey are you telling me you're
not predicting a summer of peace and uh
tranquility when the riots are coming
and they're burning cities down and cnn
cnn is telling us that it's all in the
name of tolerance and diversity yeah i
don't i don't believe anything that's
going to happen i think it's a little
bit of but the shock already happened
with the leak right i mean that already
people were that we had went through
about 48 hours of freak out and there'll
be more of that in light of this
decision but i think everything's going
to calm down and people realize that
it's a it's a state level battle the
battle will continue
in every state and things will settle
down and we'll go back to the system
we've had should have had from the very
beginning this whole issue should have
been regulated by the states according
to the constitutional structure it was
inevitable if we have a supreme court
that takes constitution seriously that
at some point roe v wade is going to be
overturned
and and
that's in the name of social peace
this is this is the right way i think it
should have happened a very long time
ago
and as i say i think we're going to have
a patchwork of laws all over the country
and unfortunately the thing that's vexed
us for all these decades which is this
national
abortions
abortion rights struggle can just go go
to the states and you can pick your
state
and and some will have liberal laws some
uh tighter
and and we'll we'll move on as a country
that's that's the way the american
system is supposed to function and i i
think i think we're gonna find that
we're okay with it i think our people on
all sides are going to be okay with it
right i'm going to disagree i'm going to
go ahead and disagree let's go yeah
with jeffrey i i look i mean i
completely agree with you in terms of
where
we should be as a country and
and yes of course and i agree that the
ruling was was was properly decided and
also that
the original roe v wade ruling
disfigured politics about this issue
for the last 50 years but i don't think
there's any hope of sort of going back
to normal and uh and and uh and like
okay everybody embrace federalism now
because the left is built um it's it's
it's
conception
of government
um in opposition to federalism
their their answer for this is not okay
well you know we lost here which means
we'll just have to suck it up and uh
and and and offer unlimited abortions in
blue states i mean yes they will do that
but um but they're the the the rationale
for their um their entire program falls
apart if they cannot get this done at a
federal level they want everything done
at a federal level so i think what's
going to happen now is is these the
rhetoric is going to be dialed up
because they understand their their
their their activist base is is smart
enough or at least that the democrats in
power let's say are smart enough to
understand that this isn't about
abortion uh as much as it's about their
entire suite of issues and really the
way they wield power the way they
conceive of
their wielding of power through the
administrative state so i think what's
going to happen now is they're going to
go full bore to try to to pack the court
in addition to all kinds of
administrative
you know fixes as you as you suggested
on the on the um on the state and local
level um but they're going to be putting
up a fight everywhere there's no
shortage of money you know i mean i
think uh you know lefty uh non-profits
and pacs and and and and sort of all
this stuff even even dark money
groups which the left has everybody's
gonna be positioned to to uh to push
this because i think they understand
exactly how much of a threat this is to
their entire program so it's interesting
it's interesting because i sense before
libby jumps in i sense we're all
probably in agreement on the idea that
there was no federally constitutional
guaranteed right to an abortion it's
simply not in the constitution so i
think most people can understand that
regardless of whether you have a
personal uh feeling uh that you should
allow abortions for a certain period of
time or not what you guys are differing
on is now how the left basically will
react so libby it's funny to me in a
weird way because the states were
already doing vastly different things on
abortion texas already had six week
limit florida which you guys know i love
and live in florida uh florida to me did
something super interesting only three
months ago the florida legislature in
this red right-wing state led by don't
say gay ron desantis passed a 15-week
ban which doesn't even go into effect
until a couple weeks from now but it
wasn't even controversial here meaning
that a state that's mostly read already
was compromising on abortion so is that
the weird thing when it comes to the
outrage that we're about to see that the
states were already making up their mind
if you won an eight and a half month
abortion congratulations gavin newsom
will do it for you personally
well i think what we're going to see
this summer i think we're going to see
radical unhinged leftist feminists
going out there and trying to burn stuff
down i don't think it's going to matter
to them that you can get an abortion in
some states and not in other states
they're going to see this as a
racist white consider cis
heteronormative
assault on freedoms and trans rights and
women's rights and every kind of
conceivable thing that they can come up
with they've already threatened it we've
seen it with that group jane's revenge
the leaderless
pro-abortion militant activist group
that's you know
started fires and put graffiti all over
the place we've seen this and they are
poised and ready for another summer of
rage it doesn't matter to them that
states can do what they want it doesn't
matter to them on gun rights that now
you know states can't necessarily just
trounce all over to a rights they don't
care about that either they want what
they want they want to control other
people they want to control americans
they want to enact their bizarre ideas
of morality and these weird values that
don't value life and that are not
concerned with personal liberty or
freedom and that's what we're gonna see
we're gonna see crazy people running
around in the streets all summer
thinking that they have a right to
destroy things just because things
didn't go their way at the federal level
so jeffrey since uh since dave and libby
are pretty much in agreement on that and
i kind of feel that too that the left
they just want power they don't have
enough voices that could calmly explain
to the radical base hey this isn't about
taking away abortion it's just about the
states thing all of that since they
don't have that my personal feeling is
yes this is obviously going to lead to a
summer of you know tolerant violence why
do you not think that that's going to
happen do you think that because the
leak may have released enough air on it
already or something uh yeah something
like that i think what we're the only
differences uh here is that i'm really
speaking about the average average
person
uh many people have decided to stop
supporting uh the democrats obviously
and and and the left because of the
insanity of the of the bright
administration i just don't believe this
is going to make a the kind of margin of
difference at the at the polls that's
really going to matter yes the
organizations are going to use it to
raise money the democrats are already
doing that the the wild extreme uh of
fanatical
left left-wing activists are going to be
out in full force but whether they're
going to be able to actually rally
enough
regular people
to get
freaked out and scared about this i just
don't believe it i mean most regular
people are
are sick of this topic and and will be
happy with this with this compromise the
activists the activists will not be and
they can make a a messy uh situation and
the democrats are desperate for some
you know way to raise money i i'm on all
their email list and of course they
started hitting this since april like ah
they're gonna take away your abortion
rights and so on but and they're gonna
continue to do that and experience some
some institutional success with this
racket but i just don't believe it's
going to rally vast numbers of the
american public enough
to stop the red wave in november i don't
i don't think it's going to do that
right and that also is sort of why
they've been planned with fire this
entire time by letting the inmates run
the asylum because now if you
allow for a summer of violence uh you
just will get more red states and more
red cities which i think we'd all
basically be happy with
i want to give jeffrey some credit real
quick because i mentioned a couple times
on the show this week because we're not
doing coving today but jeffrey you were
so right on covid from literally months
before kovid
before anyone was talking about it i
think it's worth crediting when people
get it right uh and that's also a
transition to dave because you have been
talking about this sort of like soft
secession thing for a while that the
states really just don't have much in
common anymore let cali be cali and and
will be florida here uh so you're you're
probably feeling like particularly good
today putting aside abortion in general
yes that's i mean that was my that was
my first thought is that this is so much
bigger than abortion i mean of course
it's going to encourage the big sort
which is uh which is folks moving to
more ideologically um aligned
places
in the country uh you know leaving blue
states moving to red states and then
also maybe leaving red states and moving
to blue states i mean now that's that's
really in play
um you know even libs
from uh
from blue states came down to places
like florida and texas and whatever
thinking that oh i'm in this wonderful
cocoon
of
you know miami or
austin or dallas or houston or someplace
like that
and um and you know i can live my life
in taking advantage of red state taxes
and red state
culture but i'll be insulated in my
little
in my little community that won't be all
that much different than los angeles or
brooklyn
and
and that is about to change and i'm very
happy for that change
um can i ask
an interesting question here about about
what the future looks like in terms of
abortion why wouldn't it be the case
that if you're living in a highly
restrictive state say texas
and you have an unwanted pregnancy and
you know it's regrettable and you don't
feel like you can bear the trial
is it wouldn't it just be possible to
get a plane ticket to california or new
york
is
in fact oklahoma was seeing an influx of
women from texas trying to terminate
their pregnancies so they enacted their
own restrictions on the on the practice
we've seen women from texas flying off
to colorado which has declared itself an
abortion sanctuary estate or to new
mexico california has promised not only
to allow out of state abortions but to
fund the travel for women to come to
that state and terminate their
pregnancies we've seen verizon i think
and a number of other companies citibank
i think also saying that they would fund
the
travel for women employees to go
terminate their pregnancies now at this
point these are women with jobs and
really good health care plans so it's
kind of confusing as to why they
wouldn't want to say yes to motherhood
which is literally the greatest thing on
earth ever as i can testify um
personally new york also is launching
its own program i believe to help women
come in from other states and um you
know terminate their pregnancies as well
so yeah we are going to see that shift
i'd also just like to say to um dave's
point
k conservatives come move to new york
let's take it over let's create a real
counter culture here and uh vote
conservative yeah the ship has sailed
sister i'm with roboy here in florida
now
um you know one other point in new york
one other point to your question jeffrey
is that you know i think clearly as
libby's saying the the blue states will
fund some of this and they'll be you
know barbara streisand and rosie
o'donnell can fund all the abortions
they want i suspect after six months of
funding abortions for young poor black
and latino girls in texas to get their
abortions you know bust them into cali
to get an abortion i suspect after about
six months of that the optics are gonna
look pretty bad and that'll come to a
close uh pretty quickly well it looks
like a genocide i mean it looks like a
genocide against
black babies in this country you know if
i've said this i know that a lot of
people have said this if black lives
really mattered
we would let black women know that they
can create families they can be mothers
they can be supported socially um and in
society and and and pursue this course
you know why are we so opposed to black
women becoming mothers in this country
but aren't there aren't there other
medical
procedures that people leave their own
states to get i mean i i don't know but
i mean there's probably if you got a
weird kind of cancer and you hear that
you know the the best doctor on this is
in uh wyoming so you've just got to get
there don't don't you just take a a
ticket and go there isn't that sort of
normal i mean why why can't
why can't
abortion be considered something similar
i mean it just
i mean no because
you have a lot of crazy feminists who
are opposed to that idea and we've seen
there are states where you can get
abortions all through the entire
nine months um i was reading an account
on twitter of a woman who terminated her
pregnancy literally at seven months
at seven months is infanticide there's
just no way around that
it's a horror my guys are giving me a
stat right now so uh apparently in 2013
so it's nine years ago but this still
will will illustrate something more
black children were aborted than born in
new york
2013 yeah sounds about right that tells
you that's probably probably true in
florida too florida has i believe
florida was number three in 2019 uh in
the country california doesn't even keep
stats if you want to know how many
babies are terminated in california you
cannot find the information they won't
give it to you so there's a couple of
organizations that keep track the cdc
relies on voluntary reporting from
states and the guttmacher institute i
think goes out and literally calls every
abortion provider in the country to try
and get information so
yeah but california doesn't want to let
you know how many um babies they kill
every year unreal well obviously this
story isn't going anywhere hopefully
jeffrey's right and there won't be
violence but uh we shall see what
happens let's move on to a couple other
things because it was just a weird we
always have weird weeks every week is
weird uh but the lies of the
administration and the conflicting
information from the administration and
how nobody seems coordinated and biden's
fallen off a bike and that's like his
best moment of the week uh here is uh
press secretary uh karine jean-pierre
let's i always have to note she is a
black lesbian it's very important to
tell everybody that uh contradicting
energy energy secretary uh secretary
granholm about what's going on with this
gas tax what do you say to lawmakers who
are already calling this federal gas tax
holiday a gimmick and saying best case
scenario it'll save drivers about 20
bucks a month well it there's no doubt
this is a modest if it were just the
federal gas tax right 18 cents is
you know is a modest uh you know modest
amount uh we're talking about uh you
know 18 cents
uh per gallon which is going to go a
long way if you look at
the average of states that's 30 cents
just looking at those two things that's
almost 50 cents
that's going to go a long way for three
months
okay so first off they're contradicting
each other that's fine we expect that
but also this silliness about 18 cents
and 30 cents and even if you fill up
your car every day i mean we're talking
about maybe you know 30 50 bucks a month
i'm not saying it's nothing but in light
of inflation and everything else uh this
this all just shows you these people
seemingly have no idea what's going on
reboy you don't like these people do you
i mean that goes without saying no i
mean
it's it's
look i mean it's ridiculous
the idea that
inflation here is caused by anything but
the fact that they pre they put more
money into circulation
than uh than
most other economies
um you know in the world combined in the
last two years um you know the the fact
the idea that that's got nothing to do
with it is so fanciful and absurd
that um
you know i mean look i mean i hate to
quote vladimir putin but in order to
believe it you have to be
illiterate
but
they're going to try it and um
i don't know i don't know if anyone buys
it i mean i i am uh i'm pessimistic
about the the intelligence of the
average person
so you never know
now pessimistic yeah i don't know like
the the the administration i think this
whole gas tax holiday is a trap
so the idea is that you you repeal it
and that gives a biden an opening to
attack you know every gas station in the
country and say see you need to lower
your price but the inflationary pressure
is already there the the tax itself does
not it's not a retail tax it's a
wholesale tax it's paid very early in
the structure of production
i'll make a prediction right here that i
don't think it's going to make any
difference even if it passes
but it'll allow the administration to
claim that the energy companies and the
oil companies the gas company retailers
have somehow pocketed
uh the the tax cut and that that will
provide an opening for them to do all
sorts of you know attacks and accusing
uh the sellers of of gouging so i think
the whole thing is just a big trap and
it does illustrate just how the level of
economic ignorance from this um or just
sheer lies from this administration is
shocking they don't understand price
formation the the price you pay at the
pump there's not a perfect reflection of
the costs along the production structure
prices final prices especially are
always
retrospective of previous costs
and supplies and then also speculative
of of future uh supplies and and demand
and so you have an administration
demanding lower gas prices at the same
time the waging an unrelenting
rhetorical and regulatory war on fossil
fuels
and and anything other than as janet
yellen says the wind and the sun those
are good kinds of energy right which
constitutes about 14 of american energy
consumption and the rest is evil and and
and they want to get rid of it and you
cannot inspire uh more production and
lower prices under these under these
conditions it's a war on on energy and
enterprise and it's it's outrageous and
it's hardly a surprise it's going to
lead to you know more
pressure from two directions one
monetary as david says uh but but also
the supply constraints and and refining
capacity is you know very intense right
now
and by the way they're fully admitting
that they are waging that war they're
not even hiding that they are waging
that war they're telling us they're
waging that war um and also to me it
seems if you really wanted to put a
little more money in people's pocket
instead of say a three-month federal gas
tax holiday that's going to save you
know 18 cents a gallon i know i know i'm
a radical crazy freedom extremist but
how about a i don't know one percent uh
tax cut across the board on your federal
taxes how come that isn't something they
could think about maybe we'll just take
a tiny bit less money from you uh libby
before i throw to you you guys may
remember this barack obama guy does he
ring a bell does that name sound like
something uh in 2008 he said that gas
tax holidays were complete nonsense i
know that we're having a debate right
now about the gas tax holiday
i know how brutal
this is on folks right now
and i know they need relief which is why
i've offered a middle-class tax cut for
every american a thousand dollars for
working families so that they can deal
not only with
rising gas prices but rising health care
costs and rising grocery costs
but for us to suggest that
30 cents a day
for three months
is real relief
that that's a real energy policy
means that we are not tackling the
problem that has to be tackled
man if joe biden had any clue what was
going on he would not be happy hearing
that from barack obama who he ended up
being vp for uh libby i mean obama 2008
making a lot of sense that's when it was
going to save you 30 cents a gallon now
we're only at 18 cents a gallon
yeah but what we see with this
administration consistently uh with
regard to energy and resources as well
as all of the other things uh from you
know abortion and trans rights and
whatever else we see a desire on their
part to remake american society and
remake the american economy to fit their
utopian ideal of what they think we
should be doing they don't care about
average american people they don't care
about how we're going to feed our
families they don't care about how we're
going to fill our tanks or drive around
or lead our lives in the independent and
individualistic ways that we would
prefer to no instead they want us to
rely on their own
ideas of
what they believe is appropriate whether
it's the sun and the and the wind um or
whatever else the electric vehicles that
actually run on coal power and they
refuse to actually admit that that's
what's going on our grid can't handle
this stuff and they've also been waging
a war against nuclear energy which is
profoundly stupid since nuclear energy
is clean uh efficient and effective and
could do an awful lot in order to power
and shape our economy um but no they
they have this absurd moral view and
they just want us to do what they say
and i'm so sick of it i hate it so much
libby you're giving me answers to a
problem but you're forgetting about some
other guy across the world who we have
to blame for all of our problems we even
have video of somebody blaming that guy
video
and let's remember how we got here
putin invaded ukraine
putin invaded ukraine with a hundred
thousand forces
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
all right first off yes i think a lot of
people are saying that
number two gas as we've covered here
many times was up already a dollar over
a dollar a gallon before putin went into
ukraine et cetera et cetera dave it's
pretty good to have somebody you can
blame for all of your problems i mean i
thought the job of a president was that
you know other guys do bad stuff and
you're supposed to respond in kind not
just blame them
for all of your problems
yeah i mean it's ridiculous we see that
it's ridiculous but um
it's a continuation of
what seemed to work out pretty well for
the democrats for the last five six
years which is just
putin is the boogeyman
and if you know if you were
if you were a democrat strategist
one of the smart things to do would be
to pin
negative
news and all your bad things on the guy
that you just spent five years uh uh
affirmating against
um and blaming for everything from the
2016 election to
you know to everything just put
everything else in that in that bucket
and it seems to me like the democrat
electorate
um has has thus far
accepted it
um you know i i don't think i i think
that
that crowd of people as we've seen from
the uh from the uh the approval
polling for joe biden i think that that
number is is is dropping like a stone
but still this is this is kind of what
they've got to do in order to
get the attention and the motivation of
their most hardcore supporters all right
so since you're hitting the approval
stuff let's let's just jump forward for
just a second because even the
mainstream media can't hide it anymore
it's one thing for us you know
alternative media people to be talking
about what's obviously right in front of
us but finally some reality is leaking
even
over at cnn
the consumer prices went up by 7.5
year-over-year in january before the
invasion began and that was the fastest
pace since february of 1982. it's gotten
worse since then because we've seen
prices for gasoline
natural gas go up we've seen food prices
go up and so inflation was a big problem
it's gotten even bigger clearly the
white house is searching for solutions
here but some of what we just heard
right
one not likely to get through congress
two if it gets through congress it's
gonna have a minimal impact on your
wallet right would we say uh two dollars
and seventy cents every time you fill up
your tank not a big mover and then also
it could backfire by making demand worse
it's not gonna address supply it doesn't
help the revenue situation there's a lot
of drawbacks there
i think we may have had a little audio
problem for you guys not the audience
there but in essence and i know we'd
sent you the clip before we started in
essence uh cnn is now admitting that
some of these solutions from the
administration are not solutions jeffrey
mainstream media they're starting to get
it is it possible
i'm just glad for the firing of
zucker from cnn things have changed a
lot over there uh in the end uh cnn is a
quasi-capitalistic organization and they
have to
at some point get some uh increase in
their ratings so you're seeing a little
more truth leak out
from cnn i personally don't know anybody
who believes this this putin's the the
problem with the but the price hike
thing i i think it's just so ridiculous
and maybe i'm wrong but i've noticed
that the my administration is starting
to dial that back a little bit because
it's so obviously preposterous
and at some point you'd think and this
is a question i had for libby actually
i mean you'd think that the
administration at some point would look
at his polling numbers and realize
that they're on the on the wrong path i
mean how much worse does it have to get
before these people start dialing back
their
millenarian utopian visions of the
society they want to create it's uh
it's they're being sadistic towards the
american
people and and our future and
everybody's mad at them about it i mean
the polls are absolutely horrible so why
don't we see any kind of adjustment is
it is it just ideological fanaticism you
know that that somehow prevents uh
people in biodemonstration from looking
at at the truth or what what is this my
short answer is yes but i'll i'll let
libby take that one
i do think that it's i do think that a
lot of this is ideological and that they
um think that what they are saying is
true and accurate and they've also given
so much power to the far-left
progressives
and they know that that group of people
can really tank the establishment uh
democrats and prevent them from gaining
any power at all i mean we we see the
far left willing to burn everything down
anyway so um you know if they don't have
their guy in office they're not going to
be particularly concerned about that is
my view and i think that the biden
administration knows that perhaps they
should add some of this information to
the cheat sheets for biden so that he
knows um in advance you know what he
might be looking at uh in addition to
you sit down next and things like that
um
yeah you in all caps i i found that
really rather shocking myself uh that
this is that this is what they were
doing but every time biden says that he
wants to rebuild the economy from the
bottom up and the middle out what he
means is from the top down with a big
vise yeah a big grip you know he's
saying the opposite what he means and
every time he blames putin in every one
of those speeches where he's blaming
putin for his own uh complete and total
failures he also blames trump trump's
been out of office for a long time now
and it's unclear that the you know whole
democratic establishment is going to be
able to prevent him from running again
so
yeah i think he's just really in a bad
spot and he's doing a terrible job and
everyone knows it but for some reason
maybe no one's telling him
and everything is is is destined to get
worse from all the data i'm looking at
whether it's the impending recession or
the inflationary trajectory which is
going to intensify over over time we're
going to be solidly in a a
stagflationary environment as we
approach november and nobody's
going to be able to deny it or fix it
and the administration's not going to
change its its its rhetoric and its
outlook which is just this sort of
non-stop war
on the spirit of enterprise and you know
blaming everybody else for all the
things that they actually caused but if
you look at the disasters
uh from the inflation and the impending
recession everything it almost dates
from the date of the inauguration itself
i mean it's so bad and i i do think that
a lot of the problems date further back
in time there's no question about that
but just if
you just want to line up the calendar
with with the the disasters that we're
facing right now it really does date
from the bite administration i don't see
how they can avoid the culpability for
this thing and i also i think uh you're
right libby there's there's very little
chance they're going to get they can
change their their outlook i mean as by
administration suddenly going to be in
favor of
free enterprise and sound money i mean
and you know i don't think so
guys so honestly please
jeffrey please you have to have a little
hope remember janet yellen just a week
or two ago at that hearing about uh
inflation and the recession said she
hopes that we don't hit a recession so
you know if you just believe then maybe
something will happen but you're
actually giving me a perfect segue
because it's been just disaster after
disaster
and then we found this clip from the
televised mental institution known as
msnbc where this woman her name is
michelle singletary she's basically
telling us all to shut up because well
well take a look for yourself where we
are right now
you know
i'm just going to say this and and if i
get bang for it i don't care there are
there is a great deal of americans where
it is uncomfortable that they're
spending more but they are not going to
go under you know you you got to stop
complaining when there's so many people
who literally the inflation rate means
they may only have two meals instead of
three there are americans who did
extremely well in the last two years in
the market you still have your job and
yeah it's costing you more for gas but
guess what you're still going to take
that holiday that fourth of july
vacation you could still eat out so i'm
going to need you to calm down and back
off because it feeds into this fear and
then this fear feeds into people making
decisions that creates the very thing
that they're fearful of
if there was ever a clip that perfectly
illustrates why everyone sort of hates
progressives at this point that's sort
of holier than thou
you have to do this if it's not directly
affecting you then you better shut up
and don't talk about our guy who's in
charge right now man it's libby it's the
whole thing related to media and reality
versus what they want to show us right
yeah and she's also saying
don't fight for people who are
struggling more than you which is
supposed to be their whole thing isn't
that their game their whole what
happened to you know using your
privilege to fight for people who have
less privilege no apparently not for
this woman so basically everything she's
saying is actually anathema to her
entire program which is help people who
are doing worse than you but now she's
saying don't help people who are doing
your worse than you because they're
doing worse than you
so why would you want to call attention
to that why would you want to call
attention to the struggle
exactly right i mean the rich are fine
with inflation i mean chanel handbags
just went up 60 percent and they're
increasing in sales it's like like the
the sort of the next level uh luxury
good you know and it's so it's fine for
the richer fine inflation creams the
poor in the middle class it's a disaster
and and and uh
really is a theft
of their time and their labor and their
property and people absolutely despise
it it really does represent a transfer
of wealth
from the poor and the middle class from
the the
very poor all the way up to the
high bourgeoisie up to the most elite
sectors of society in the administrative
state and they're very very well to do
who don't feel inflation at all that's
what inflation represents
and that's why people despise it very
good yeah and that and we just saw in
kovid so much of that so much of a
wealth transfer right so much of the
depletion of the wages of the working
class and the increase in the um you
know pocket books of the incredibly
wealthy and now the administration is
just continuing that trend and we're now
supposed to look the other way now we're
not supposed to care that poor people
are having a tough time you know
groceries in new york city obviously and
everywhere are skyrocketing we see this
all the time i personally just buy way
way less stuff that my kid wants you
know i'm just like nope we're not
getting that we're not getting that uh
over you know and after that we're gonna
do intermittent fasting
yeah in for the to uphold the religion
of the bible administration not for any
reasonable uh moral standards
the other thing is that if you notice
what she's saying she's saying shut up
she's got no answer she
she's not even concerned with
okay how do we solve this this is a
thing that must be solved how do we
solve it
um that's not on the menu and and
frankly it it's it's really telling
because it's never been on the menu for
the left how do we solve this
um this
wealth
issue or how do we solve this cost of
living issue is never what they care
about what they all the only thing they
care about are are disparities
and um and and sort of managing
managing those disparities whether it be
turning up the heat in terms of um
in terms of the you know the the getting
the poor to hate the rich or um in terms
like this where she's just trying to say
just shut up and and and lay low because
this economy is being transformed and
you know as as you guys have have have
said uh
it's all about you know it's it's uh
the war on the middle class is something
that goes back
um on the left to the very very
beginning and um
it's it's every everything that that
the um everything that that biden has
done and of course with covet is just
exacerbating that wealth transfer from
the middle classes up until the uh you
know the the the
chanel handbag class
all right well we are going to end on
this because it is my birthday weekend
my birthday is on sunday and we've
talked about the depressing state of the
economy and the crazy people in the
media and our president whose head's not
on straight i would like each one of you
to give me hope that i can have a nice
weekend despite all of this jeffrey you
first
well you always have a nice weekend uh
you're more optimistic than i am i mean
which is saying something uh look i i
actually think we're at a a great moment
in american history we're finally
confronting the kind of despotic
tyrannies that have surrounded us for
really a very long time and we're having
to come to terms with the power of the
administrative state we're we've lost
faith in our our central institutions
whether it's the cdc or the fda or the
fed or
uh anything else and i i think to me
it's just like the dawning of reality in
america
and we really have to ask the question
what kind of system do we want we want
did the constitution have anything to
teach us is freedom a good thing these
are the kinds of questions we're asking
and i'm very optimistic that in the end
the american people will have the right
answers and we're going to engage in the
right kind of reforms it might take five
years but i think we're going to get
there jeffrey that's definitely the
title of your next book the dawning of
reality that's it right there you just
i'm i'm announcing it right here you're
writing that book dave give me a little
hope
all right well i was with you last year
on your birthday when you live in
california
and uh so so this year is going to be a
marked improvement
and this you know as we know birthdays
are an occasion to
maybe come to grips with our own more
mortality and
you know um see that the the the war
against the deterioration of the mind
and body
um
uh is is one that we will eventually
lose like joe biden
but
we're doing great you're doing great
florida is doing great
and
the trajectory
is upward
libby i was born in brooklyn where you
are i now live in florida is that the
greatest birthday gift one could be
given
that's pretty great my son was born in
brooklyn uh and he will live in florida
one day yeah one day he will uh texas
more like it if he has his way but this
is a great weekend to celebrate this is
spectacular america has chosen life and
perhaps there will be many many more
birthdays
this year than there would have been
otherwise so i think you should make
merry and enjoy that
wow libby tying this thing together like
a true pro uh you guys were awesome i'd
love to have the three you back together
really enjoyed this have a great weekend
guys and i'm gonna finish up uh direct
to camera in just a moment so i'll talk
to you guys soon happy birthday thanks
guys happy birthday
all right people
that's it for the week i have to tie a
few loose ends together today we got a
couple meetings coming up and there's a
bunch going on at the house and then uh
i'm taking the crew i'm taking you guys
out for my birthday how did that happen
who's in charge around here all right
you know what michael you're using the
corporate card i know i pay for it but
at least you throw the card down
you oh are you your tip
some other time i'll tell you about
michael in the tips he's uh he's the
most stringent tipper known to man
he
he needs like a waiter that will like
act like a clown for him like dance for
me otherwise he refuses and i'm an
overtipper i i feel that these people
are working hard they should be extra
tipped anyway i'm not doing much this
weekend we're going to relax hang out
with friends eat some good food and
lounge in the pool and that's about it i
hope you will uh escape from some of the
madness yourself obviously
you know especially the abortion stuff
like this is i i tend to think that uh
jeffrey was being a little pollyannish
unfortunately and that this is going to
lead to some more violence and the fuel
that unfortunately the left needs
because the policies aren't working and
and i was really focusing on that this
week if all the stuff that you're doing
isn't working you need distractions so
you need to keep people enraged about
abortion or you need to keep people
fearful that kovid's coming back or
monkey pox or whatever it might be uh
but i know that you guys watch this show
so you're not hysterical and you're not
crazy lunatics and that's why i dig you
anyway have a nice weekend and on monday
i'll be 46 years old 46 are you going to
watch a
youtube show of a guy that's 46 we'll
find out all right have a good guys